well thank you for joining us for the
buyer process next Summit today
we've created this forum for you
biologics developers and manufacturers
those of you that are shaping the future
of biologics
there's no denying it these therapies
are changing the world and transforming
lives by providing better treatments the
future of biologics and its growing
potential to benefit patients with unmet
medical needs has perhaps never been
more promising and the market reflects
that it is anticipated that 70 percent
of new drug approvals are expected to be
biologic by the end of the decade
we are where we are today because
individuals and companies like yours
have worked on some of the world's
biggest challenges
those advances and discoveries have led
us to where we are moving into a world
of emerging Therapies
we are starting to tackle orphan
diseases
we're getting better at reducing
symptoms and side effects by being more
targeted with the molecules that we're
developing
and we have one common theme that drives
us why we all do what we do and that is
to find a better way to make the world
healthier
with that in mind I'm honored to
introduce our next speaker Brendan
Connors is a melanoma veteran and
Survivor
historian spies me not only due to the
impact and availability of better
Therapies but also because timing was
such a critical factor in his story
as an introduction to Brendan we had
permission to share a short video that
Brendan produced in partnership with the
stand-up to cancer initiative
I always had the travel bug but not like
this it was one of those things where
you just realize how short life can be
and there is a lot of places that we
wanted to see when realizing why am I
waiting to do it why don't we just do it
as soon as possible I'm Brandon Connors
I'm 35 and I am a metastatic melanoma
cancer survivor back in 2010 I scratched
a mole on my back and my younger brother
was like you know you're backs bleeding
so I went to a dermatologist they did a
pre-biopsy and saw that it was
pre-cancerous they found out that there
was a mass underneath my shoulder that's
where the cancer had actually spread to
some way went from the left side of my
shoulder in an area and then made it
into my right bone of my leg and it was
one of those things where it was kind of
like surreal where like by the way you
had stage four metastatic melanoma
[Music]
I was able to then enter into this
clinical trial I was going through an
immunotherapy process and what
immunotherapy essentially is it's taking
the cells in your body and it's actually
teaching them that cancer is bad so your
own cells are then fighting the cancer
cells they were monitoring to see how
the cancer was continuing to shrink my
last actual treatment was about five
years ago and I've been cancer-free
since then so towards the end of the
treatment was when I was turning 30 and
I wanted to put something together that
was going to make everything you know
worthwhile I wanted to make a list of
things that I could do and should do and
I thought 30 things in the year 30 would
be a great way to kind of do that my
goal was to finish all 30 things by the
time my 31st birthday happened for 30
and 30 we decided to go to the Havasupai
Falls which is in the western of the
Grand Canyon it's a solid 11 mile hike
and then you come upon this beautiful
waterfall this is actually the first
time where I told my girlfriend at the
time right now wife that I love her
we were in Italy we ended up going up to
Lake Garda I decided that the best part
would be to surprise her and get engaged
in a castle overlooking the water with
mountains in the background and she had
no idea that it was coming and it was
absolutely beautiful
we were at Rainbow Mountain part of the
two-day hike was actually camping
overnight at 14 000 feet just sleeping
was tough because the air was just so
thin we got to the peak of it and it was
16 300 feet which is essentially taking
three empire state buildings and putting
them on top of each other you don't
really know the limits of kind of where
your body can actually take you until
you actually push it and you don't have
a choice for pushing it when you're
going through different kind of
therapies you just have to trust that
you know your body is strong enough and
that it will do it being able to
struggle through actually breathing as
you walk to the top of the mountain was
just one of those realizations that all
these trips that were going on and you
want to step back and think about the
reason why we're doing all this and how
it has like a larger meaning while I was
posting some of these a lot of people
didn't know that I was actually going
through Outpatient Treatment while the
photos on social media look you know
great there is obviously always that
story that goes down behind my advice to
someone that's currently battling cancer
is just keep your head up knowing how
far you've come already and just staying
positive
so what an inspiring video Brendan I'm
really pleased to welcome you thank you
for joining us today there's a lot to
learn from your journey can you tell us
a little bit about yourself and your
life before your cancer Journey began
sure sure first off thank you for having
me I'm super excited to be here
um my name is Brennan Connors I'm now 39
years old I was born in New York City I
grew up in Long Island New York and New
Jersey went to college in Pennsylvania
at the University of Scranton I swam
competitively in high school and in
college my favorite stroke was the
butterfly and the individual medley I
lived in New York City for about 14
years we're currently working in digital
advertising I got married in 2016
recently moved to Connecticut my wife
and I have traveled to over 40 countries
since being married and I have a
beautiful and amazing little 21 month
old daughter right now
it's great uh Brennan how did you first
learn that you had cancer what was the
the process of diagnosis and treatment
for you
so I first learned um that I had that
something was wrong I was living in New
York City with my younger brother and I
had
scratched a mole on my back and he was
like that's really ugly like you should
get that checked out so made an
appointment for a dermatologist and
turned out that um it was pre-cancerous
so from the time that I had that first
checked out to my first actual uh cancer
diagnosis was about six months of um
that full process
so in terms of kind of what that
timeline looks like so may of 2010 like
I mentioned that was the pre-cancerous
mole first surgery was in was in June at
Mount Sinai where they actually dug out
all around the actual mold and did a
bunch of tests I also had a lymph node
dissection because they weren't sure
that the moles in the middle of my back
which which area was in so they did it
on both the right and the left side and
then in November I got the call that I
was a metastatic
melanoma cancer patient
um from there everything kind of just
took off
um we went through the process of trying
to figure out where to go
um so had appointments at Mount Sinai in
New York City at appointments at Yale
ended up luckily being placed into a
trial down at NIH and NCI
so that started in January
um as you can see from the timeline I
was down there for about a month and it
was discharged when it's going back and
forth to NIH and MCI for a few months
and then in July
and they saw that the cancerous area
within my left shoulder had actually
started to increase a little bit
um the area within my right leg was
totally gone so the focus was just
solely on the left side
so from there I ended up going into a
second treatment at Sloan Kettering I
was on that all outpatient for about a
year and then from there continued doing
doing scans through the last final year
and then as of September 2012 that was
my last Outpatient Therapy
so in terms of kind of the overall
clinical trials like I mentioned I was
within two of them uh the first one was
at NIH and NCI the second one was at
memorial stone Kettering the first one
uh was a combination of a week-long of
chemo
um for about seven days and then from
there it was interleukin 2 which I did
about six rounds which is one round
every eight hours so it lasted about two
days doing that and then the second one
was at memorial stone Kettering which is
all outpatient which was a combination
drug treatment of aluminab and Ebola map
which was 12 rounds total for about 12
months
um and once again that was all
outpatient
[Music]
so I would like to explore a little bit
more about the clinical trials you're
involved with and and the timing and
availability of these trials was so
important in your case
if we move to the next slide we'll see
and Based on data from the journal of
clinical oncology prior to 2010 almost
all patients died from Advanced melanoma
so how were the trials and therapies
that you participated in different from
what was available previously to
melanova patients
yeah I mean thinking back to when I
started my child to where we are today
is really breathtaking uh my
dermatologist would remind me ever he
still does remind me every time I see
him that I'm lucky to be alive
um and the doctors would tell me that
you know this treatment is new or we
don't have a lot of information or a lot
of data on on what we're going to be
going through at this point you're one
of the first to ever do this treatment
or you're the first on this combination
of treatments so it was really you know
the beginning of full-on
um treatments and I remember my brother
so he's also a doctor as well he was at
a conference and he sent me a text
message it was a picture of of a chart
similar I guess to this chart and he
circled the end of it he said this is
essentially you that's who they're
talking about of you know the the tail
end of this where they're still learning
from what you have gone through and that
was it was kind of you know
crazy to think about that I was
trailblazing in a way and I didn't even
realize I was I was I was doing that
um but this chart you know is just one
of those really amazing
things to look at seeing kind of where
it was and where we are now
so in terms of kind of immunotherapy and
T cells you heard me mentioned a little
bit in the video but I had to start
figuring out a way to explain it to
people that weren't within the
immunotherapy area friends cousins
um so
I was able to go into the labs at NIH
and NCI and really kind of explore what
was going on so the way that I started
explaining this to people was that you
know first you need to have good cells
that understand that you know they are
the good sales versus the cancer culture
or the bad cells and then you need to
extract those cells from the body and
harvest them within a lab and actually
teach them that cancer is bad so
my cells were being taught that cancer
was bad within the labs of NIH and NCI
and they started to then grow those
cells once the doctor saw that they
understood that the cancer was bad so
when I say that they they they grew them
it was 50 plus billion cider cells so to
speak that was then moved from the Petri
dishes within NIH and then moved back
inside of me to then continue to fight
those cancer cells and then my body was
then used as a incubator to continually
grow those cells and continue those
cells to continue to fight
um off all of the bad cancer cells which
is essentially how I'm describing
immunotherapy
foreign
so these pictures here is kind of what I
was just talking about the one on the
the left is myself actually getting an
opportunity to go into the labs and see
what they were doing with myself and how
they were quote unquote training myself
to be cancer Fighters the second one is
me holding that entire second row is
actually all of my cells and then that
third picture is what all of those cells
look like right after uh or right before
they were going to be put back inside of
me after the week-long of Chemo when I
became neutropenic right before starting
um the the il-2 process so like I said
before in terms of kind of
first then interleukin-2 in terms of
some of the side effects chemotherapy
fatigue loss of appetite hair loss and
as a competitive swimmer you know going
from
having hair to not having hair wasn't
that big of a deal it was just all the
rest of everything that kind of was the
shocking part of it for interleukin 2
and we'll get into that on the following
slides it was
definitely an experience I will not
forget I like to compare that to a movie
it's called The Fighter
so there's a scene in the movie where
um
being played by Christian Bell is being
weaned off of cocaine and he's actually
in a jail cell and he cannot control
himself and his body is freaking out and
it's convulsing and when I was going
through the aisle tube that's actually
what I kept on thinking about I had
watched the movie recently to getting on
to il-2 and
it you weren't able to like control so I
had a Hickman catheter and the advantage
of that was being able to have the
nurses come in give me medicine which
then calms my body down but the il-2 was
a dose every eight hours so three times
a day so I made it through
um basically two days and I was about to
go on to the next dose and my doctors
came in they were monitoring everything
and my oxygen levels had depreciated and
they're like well that's that's all we
can do in my head I was like no I can do
one more my doctor's like no you
definitely can't do one more um and I
guess that was kind of that mentality of
that movie The Fighter thinking that I
was actually part of that
um but that was an experience for for IL
too
so in terms of the second clinical trial
that I was on this was at memorial stone
Kettering which was the first time that
they did the combination drug at the
lumab and nivolumab this was all
outpatient therapy and
was a total of 12 months and overall
this clinical trial compared to the
first one was a breeze for me personally
um I didn't have to redo chemo the side
effects
them all I only had one overarching uh
time where I had to get additional
treatment which was essentially just
giving me a steroid I had some rashes
which puts me into the ER but overall it
was actually much easier to to deal with
as an outpatient than actually going
through the first trial
and some of the outpatient therapies and
you heard me say this in the video as
for people to kind of repost to social
media I was going to playing beach
volleyball games in New York City after
um going through an actual treatment
because I wanted to keep that self of of
normalcy so I wanted to continue to live
my life and I didn't want this to slow
me down and if you're looking at the
picture and you're thinking is that an
umbrella in what looks like contrast
you're right
um every time I would go in Sloan they
would ask you whether you wanted your
contrast to be room temperature or if
you wanted it to be refrigerated and I
always said refrigerated with an
umbrella Please and I guess I said it
one too many times so after one of the
times going in I asked for it and I
asked for my umbrella and the nurses
behind the counter gave me an umbrella
it's amazing I I know Brendan I'll never
look at those fall umbrellas the same
way again that's for sure a great
reminder of uh your amazing journey that
you're sharing with us so would you mind
telling us a little bit more about some
of the key things that you learned
through this this whole process
sure
um so I've detailed out a bunch of kind
of the learnings and takeaways and I
think for everyone that goes through
treatments you are learning things
differently and your takeaways are very
different it's very um individualistic
for me personally
um the first thing I realized was that
cancer is is not a choice you don't
choose to get cancer it's not like
you're going in to buy a car and you're
getting the choice of you know do you
want to buy a Toyota Camry or do you
want to buy a Maserati I mean you don't
get the choice you kind of you know it's
chosen to you so you you have to just
play the hand that you're dealt which
leads me to the second which is kind of
control what you can and don't worry
about what you can't
um you can't control getting you know
cancer and getting how bad it is but
what you can control is super important
and I learned to not actually worry
about things that I couldn't worry about
and you know things today when people
complain about the weather it drives me
crazy it's one of those things where you
just know you have no control over it
um so just to kind of put everything
context just kind of control what you
can
always bring a positive attitude because
that's something that you can control so
when you're going into treatments or
you're going in for scans or for
checkups
I feel like the you know that that
positive power that you have within
yourself is something that's super
important and if you think positive then
positive things will happen and creating
something to look forward to I know
we've kind of
talked about the 30 things in 30 but for
me it was important to have something to
look forward to and it doesn't have to
be something that's that's Grand or
overarching but even something small
just to kind of keep your mind off of
what is currently going on
um it definitely helps a lot
support systems you know whether it's
a parent whether it's a grandparent a
friend a cousin
um or even just you know there's
a slew of different other
um opportunities for people to then
become a support system whether it's
through
um grants or processes within the
hospitals themselves you know having
someone to talk to or someone that's
been through that process that you can
just kind of bounce ideas off of what
things you may be going through with
someone that gets it is super important
which is one of the reasons why I tend
to do these types of webinars and you
know reach out to individual people
because I want people to know that there
are the people that have gone through it
um and I always said to myself it can
always be worse I know that's a weird
thing to say for someone that was you
know my dermatologist says that I should
be dead and
um
but it's true when I was down at NIH
there was people that I met on the floor
that are no longer with us because
theirs was worse than mine
um whether it was you know any different
forms of cancer so to always put that in
perspective is something that I
continually reminded myself and that
kind of went back to how cancer Wilson
of choice can happen a positive attitude
um
your doctors nurses and scientists
I don't know everything there is to know
about melanoma and I don't know
everything there's no about cancer in
general I know enough but definitely not
people that have spent their entire
lives dedicating themselves to to the
science of it so you have to go through
this process especially when you're
you're signing these forms and it says
your side effects could be anything from
you know aches pains nausea diarrhea or
death
you have to trust that your doctors and
your nurses have your your best self
um in mind and that they are doing what
they have been taught and trained and
you know that's what they are there to
do clinical trials
um I probably I definitely wouldn't be
here without them so they they they save
lives and they're super important to
make sure that the next person that is
going through it has a better chance of
surviving
um and that leads into you know medical
advancements are happening and they're
happening because people are brave
because they're going through clinical
trials
um and they're happening all the time
and even if they're small little pieces
or little things that happen from time
to time it ends up growing into
something much much bigger
foreign
doctor at memorial stone Kettering and I
had asked him if he had a quote that he
would like to um to have within this
presentation
um webinar and I'll read the quote uh he
said the improvements in the treatment
of advanced melanoma continued to be an
exciting and wild ride I hope it will
continue and once everything has had a
great outcome then I will be able to
retire early quite happily
um it's been a great opportunity to work
with uh Dr Passau and you know I
part of my personality was obviously
keeping everything you know
real so to speak so I usually don't call
him Dr pasta I usually I just call them
uh DMP Dr Mike or Dr Mike pastow
um and him and I have done some webinars
together as well and having a
relationship with your doctor where you
know you if you need anything or just
have questions or if you're doing
something like this you know you're able
to kind of give him a call or text an
email and you know he's right there to
kind of help along the way
great really appreciate the reflections
and especially the the learnings and
takeaways that you shared with us really
applicable to all of us I think in in in
so many ways so thanks for that you know
you touched again as you did on the
video on on 30 things at 30. um please
tell us just a little bit more about
that and just what it meant for you
sure
um
so while I was sitting at NIH and MCI
One Night in between treatments I
started to make a list a list of things
that I wanted to do things I just you
know wanted to have things that I
thought I would never be able to get and
the list grew and grew and grew and I
kept adding to it
um so I started troops when I was 27 and
when I was turning 28 which happened to
be my golden birthday on board on
February 28th so 28 28 which I didn't
realize was a thing until I was coming
through all this and someone would
remind me oh that's your golden birthday
that's like a big deal
so I decided that after treatment I was
going to do something that was a big
deal so I always wanted a Jeep Wrangler
so on my 20th birthday I walked into a
dealership I said who wants to sell me a
Wrangler I'm walking out with one today
and I walked out with the Wrangler on my
20th birthday I drove home to my parents
house and they were like how did you get
here I didn't own a car before
um and it was my dream part and it was
one of those things that I always wanted
um and then to keep up with that I
always wanted it was wanted a jet ski so
I I ended up buying a Jet Ski leading
into that summer I was something might
be thinking you're a melanoma Survivor
you have a convertible and a jet ski
probably not the most ideal thing for
melanoma location but I promise I have a
huge bottle of sunscreen with me at all
times any time that I um use the
convertible part or I go out on the jet
ski so that was the first two things and
I still had this enormous list
of things that I had created and I was
trying to figure out the best way to
kind of do some of the things so I
decided when I turned 30 why not create
30 things to do in 30 so 30 things I
could do before turning 31
um and my girlfriend now wife at the
time
instrumental in making sure that I stuck
to this list and made sure that I was
able to get it done you can see the list
a little on the left but some of the
things I'll just highlight um when
skydiving I recommend it people might
think you're crazy for doing it you
should totally do it it's an amazing
experience
um hiking to the bottom of the Grand
Canyon and then camping at the bottom of
the Grand Canyon was was amazing I
always wanted to for whatever reason
stand in four states at one time so New
Mexico Arizona Utah and Colorado the
Four Corners
um did that we went white water rafting
uh learn to rock climb went rock
climbing in Garden of the Gods which was
amazing run a half marathon
I don't think I'll ever do a full
Marathon I think the half marathon was
enough for me
uh to drive the Pacific Coast Highway in
a convertible I recommend anyone if
you're going to do it definitely Drive
South so that you're actually on the
water side the post or driving north
um we went dog sledding I learned to
snowboard I was a skier growing up
um and figured you know why not try
something as well so learn how to
snowboard and then also ice climbing uh
if you've never gone ice climbing it's
very interesting knowing that each time
that you're moving up that individual
ice you have to make a new you know Mark
in order to move up so it was pretty
cool
it sounds absolutely awesome I you know
I don't know if skydiving is for
everybody but there's definitely some
something on that list for everyone
right that's for sure
you know one of the things that really
sticks with me is how your treatments
rank parallel to the transition from
conventional treatments to to
immunotherapies for melanoma and during
this time we saw how the introduction of
this new class of immunotherapies
specifically the checkpoint Inhibitors
epilemia mad and the volume at help to
transform melanoma treatment resulting
in higher efficacy and better outcomes
for patients and the success of these
treatments led to additional studies and
approval of further indications of these
treatments
could support So as we move to the next
slide and we see that the impact on
patient outcomes has been very
significant death rates for melanoma had
been on the rise since the early to mid
1980s and after the introduction of
these new therapies the death rate had
one of the most dramatic decline seen
for any cancer over such a short period
of time
in our industry we're all focused on
bringing better treatments to Market
more quickly and making them more
accessible to more people
Brendan's story really brings our Need
for Speed into sharp Focus
and for me another situation that
highlighted how important timing can be
is something that we're all still
experiencing at the moment and that's
the covid-19 crisis and and the pandemic
our industry has always focused on
developing life-saving therapies and
vaccines but the pandemic created an
urgency era in our industry that really
allowed us to move more quickly and
collaborate more openly than ever before
we know how important timing is for
patients and their families and so I
challenge us all to think about what
we've learned from the pandemic which in
many ways has been the finest Hour of
Biotech and Pharma what have we learned
and how can we apply it every day to
support the development of new therapies
going forward
so so Brendan you know with the pandemic
what have you learned through the course
of the pandemic for you specifically
I was lucky enough that I was I was
agreements by the time the pandemic
started so I was super thankful for that
but I could not think about those that
had to postpone or delay treatment or
even cancel treatments because of the
pandemic and I've heard that cancer
screenings do the pandemic have
plummeted and you know doctors are
worried that this next year to two year
gap on the screenings will have a severe
impact in years to come I also learned
that the work that the scientists and
researchers and doctors do on a daily
basis is incredibly important I mean
sure it may you know it took the
pandemic to really Shine the Light on
the importance of mRNA which I didn't
know until the pandemic of how important
that really is in creating the covid-19
vaccine but to think that that Daily
Grind of those individuals working on
mRNA on something that seems important
but not like the most important thing of
our lifetime is just is is wild to me
um I was also reminded on how lucky I
was you know I was getting emails from
doctors and hospitals that I had
treatment at
allowing you know people to sign up to
then skip the line if you were
immunocompromised if you've had previous
illnesses so that you could get the
vaccine sooner
um but since I was 100 work from home I
wasn't on Trials I had no side effects I
didn't feel it was appropriate for me to
kind of take one of those positions from
someone so I was lucky enough based on
everything that I had gone through to
decline the opportunity to jump the line
or be the next in the line and really
hope that by doing that someone else
that was you know situated behind me was
able to get that spot and hopefully that
made them stay healthy and potentially
even you know go on with their
additional screenings for whatever they
were going through
foreign
thank you for having me today but just
the the last part that I would just
saying is just a huge thank you
um to the doctors that I have come
across within my life
um and it's not just a thank you to them
it's a thank you for today for me and
more importantly and thank you for
tomorrow
um and the quote that I have here on the
screen um it reads you don't realize
what you have until it's gone by the
time you realize what you had it's too
late live every day to the fullest be
yourself and love yourself for it
um it's kind of a mantra that I've
always always had and I think it brings
true even more uh today and more
um every day every single day
right well thank you very much Brendan
for sharing your story with us today we
we really appreciate your time and
taking us through your Brave and
successful journey and we certainly wish
you all the very best for the future I'd
like to also thank the audience for
joining us today uh this present
presentation actually concludes our
agenda for the day but please don't
leave the event just yet and I invite
you to visit the virtual exhibit boots
the upstream and downstream process
development labs and also our scientific
poster Hall
you'll find lots of solutions and
Technical expertise there that will
surely help your biomanufacturing
process
but thanks again Brendan and thank you
everybody
thank you